so here we are once more with more
godzilla vs gong teasers
which actually was due at the end of the
month it seems the producers were a bit
generous this time around owing to the
fact that they have been holding out
on teasers and trailers for quite a
while now
anyway we are happily obliged to give
you guys the teaser breakdown and before
we go
into it i just want to say that the last
trailer was
mostly gone centric and this one
is the same but in a different light we
see new glimpses of the future battle
and what's in store for all of us and
also we see the scenes that would make
maybe reveal the true nature of the
battle so anyway
let's do this thing so the first set of
scenes we see jia the little orphan girl
walking outside towards the heavy rain
which is likely the same scene as when
kong was sitting staring at the chains
but here in this teaser he seems a
little bit off
and annoyed at the iron shackles that
hold him in one place
he actually seems visibly angry but i
think jia is kind of like the big gun
that batman uses to cool down
a resurrected superman g is kinda like
lois lane in this movie
she keeps kong calm and in check and
they then touch
hands like before in the first trailer
like a boop i'm here with you till the
end
so moving on we see the same scenes
where kong taunts godzilla's saying come
at me bro
and wham godzilla slams into the ship
but we also see the ship
keeling over and kong falling down from
it desperately trying to hold on
i think this is where the first teaser
given to us in december connects
you know the one where godzilla is
swimming aggressively underwater towards
something and now we know it might be
kong
in this scene right here we can still
see the chains of kong which means that
they are a hindrance to him fighting
godzilla
and that is why he is struggling quite a
lot and almost looks like he's
gonna drown yeah so we are
we see the same scene where fighter jets
fire missiles at the g-man
which basically will have no effect on a
monster that survives the blast
effect from a nuclear weapon then we
have a very cool scene of godzilla and
his atomic breath
i think as the most of us progresses
godzilla seems to evolve more and more
into an ultimate creature as you can see
the 2014 version had no blue glowing
eyes the 2019 only had a slight bluish
tint
and now he has gone super saiyan with
his powers
and in the next shot we see godzilla's
still slamming kong
and this sends kong flying towards the
skyscraper and into the ground
i think it's pretty cool with godzilla
using his tail i think because
kong is so agile and has more flexible
limbs the tail would be one of
godzilla's hidden card tricks
as i said before this teaser is again
like the first trailer centered around
gong
which makes sense as he has had only one
movie in the monster verse and godzilla
recently had kotm
for his backstory and setting up the
character in concrete
so here we have kong seemingly
unconscious it doesn't really mean that
he's dead
it might just be the end of the
climactic battle with godzilla and he
loses only
for mecha godzilla to interrupt and
fight godzilla giving him some time to
breathe
here later jia says please be careful in
sign language
which might mean that kong will actually
step in to help godzilla destroy
the mechanized iron and the world really
does need kong
then we get another glimpse of the
climactic battle between kong and
godzilla and here
unlike the trailer sees godzilla giving
the blows which seems fair enough
as the g-man was seen being dominated in
the one before
and now we see him actually dominating
the fights with kong
i think this battle is before the scene
of gong lying on the ground
we can also see that the people are tiny
on the 100th floor or so
and the two titans battling it out would
be apocalyptic to someone
in the building anyway in this shot we
see kong holding the battle axe
and it has glowed blue meaning it has
already absorbed quite a lot of the
atomic breath
then again we see mega godzilla and the
buildings destroyed with his apparent
activation
then lastly we have a series of shots of
the battle in the ocean between godzilla
and kong
it is seen here that kong finally breaks
his shackles
with his own two hands and standing on
top of the aircraft carrier he still
doesn't bow down or lay low even in
godzilla's domain
we now see godzilla slowly approach the
aircraft carrier which would connect
with the scene of kong
punching him and godzilla then slapping
kong and then kong
body slams and pushes him back into the
water which will lead to godzilla
shooting the atomic breath
at the ship from under it here we see
how kob might actually survive the whole
battle
he is seen jumping from one ship to
another like playing super mario
this tactic might work until godzilla
just gets distracted
with another biosignal or something else
that might be used to pacify his anger
or call him to another place
i really don't see a line of ships
connecting to the mainland so it's
either that
or kong falls down a rabbit hole and
into the hollow earth
so yeah that's that the 31st of march in
the us
and the 26th worldwide now we come to
the end of the video
do you like for support subscribe if you
haven't and slap that bell button
for regular updates on more godzilla vs
kong dissection videos
take care fam